[Laughter]
thank you
thanks for inviting me to give a talk
here
um yes I'm going to be talking about our
new uh tfmb class tpd
um yeah
[Laughter]
um
it started yeah okay
um yeah so I'm going to be talking about
there's actually a talk behind this
um I'm gonna be talking about kind of
the connections between proof complexity
circuit complexity and TBD tfn Pages
I'm on like five hours of sleep here so
last uh talk of the workshop
uh yes this is
this can be kind of a survey talk kind
of based on some work with uh sambus and
Russell and paliatso
um yeah so in the past few years there's
been some like really exciting work
around this area connecting monotone
circuit complexity and proof complexity
I'm gonna try to elucidate why these
connections are occurring um so on one
hand we have monotone circuit complexity
um and in this area we had some model of
monotone circuit here's just a monotone
circuit model you should think it's just
like a computational like a non-uniform
computational model that computes a
monitoring functions
um
our task is to compete some monotone
function
um and we're interested in what the
smallest monotone Association
the circuit model is for computing this
function f
um so then over in proof complexity we
have the excellent proof system uh we
will want to prove that some formulas of
tautology
um and we're interested with the
smallest P proof of assets
okay um and so recently uh there's been
like a ton of major uh breakthroughs
that have kind of come from
um uncovering deep connections between
these areas like a lot of this work on
like lifting theorems and uh stuff from
like interpolation theorems this is all
connected to interplays between these
two areas which initially look very uh
kind of different like why would you
think
um yeah so on one hand we have
interpolation theorems which you should
think of ways to translate uh proofs
um in for complexity over into circuits
circuit complexity in the other
direction
um these query to communication lifting
theorems translate roughly translate
um circuits back into proofs
yeah and so the upshot really is that
we're able to use tools from one area uh
to analyze problems in another area this
kind of change of perspective it's
really uh
um okay so yeah why do these connections
occur
um and uh kind of the world of tfnp has
has kind of emerged as a road map for
these interpolation lifting theorems has
kind of started to like explain why
these are happening
um so
uh
to understand why these two things are
connected
um we can take a look at like
intermediary models you can think of
each of these interpolation theorems and
create communication lifting theorems as
going via sort of query and
communication problems and um Dima
talked a little bit about this in his
talk
um so on one hand we have
um monotone circuit complexity is uh as
as well aware is like
equivalent sort of to the study of this
monotone karshmer vendors in game in
certain models of communication
complexity so you have that a
Monaco circuit is is roughly equivalent
to a protocol and communication
complexity for solving the monotone
cartoon pictures
uh yeah the monitor encouragement
reducing gain is just you're given like
Alice is given your you have some
function f Alice is given a one to the
function Bob is given the zero of the
function their their goal is to separate
the one from the zero so we want to find
an index where the
um
should actually not be
not equal that should be equator
so they want to witness that the X thing
is
and similarly that we have like a sort
of a characterizing
um problem over here for proof
complexity which is the false clause
search problem so roughly proof
complexity is it's equivalent up to
squinting
um to the uh query complexity of this
false clause search problem so this is
given a so you have some unsatisfiable
CNF Formula F and you're given a truth
assignment and you want to Output an
index of a clause falsified by that
truth assignment so it's basically
witnessing that for every truth
assignment there is
foreign
and point is that these are both uh
total search problems
there's probably the monotone carbon
papers
okay so
um tfnp studies the complexity of
computing these total subscriptions and
it organizes them into a variety of
classes based on complete uh problems
these are like existence problems
generally so here's
um
there's the standard landscape of tfnp
we have at the top the class tfnp of all
uh total efficiently verifiable search
problems uh we don't think that there's
I mean there's strong evidence that
there's no complete problems for this so
people have
um broken the uh the broken key of NP
down into a variety of subclasses
um each characterized by yeah some
complete usually combinatorial or
existence
is characterized by the the pigeonhole
principle
um PPA is how we're you know you want to
witness to every odd degree vertex for
everyone degree vertex there's another
one
um and PLS is that every dag has a sink
so I'll talk a little bit more about PLS
so let's actually Define it
um so this is the sync of dag problem so
yeah so keypads is contained
oh good yeah sorry okay this diagram's a
little bit wrong yes
yes also there would be an arrow up to
uh
um
yeah uh so uh PLS is a complete problem
is this sink of dag problems you're
given
vertices one up to n and the input
variables are these successor pointers
so they give you for each vertex
um you get a successor of that vertex
like an edge going to another vertex uh
the successor has to be at least as
large as that vertex so like one can
point to one uh or anything above it two
you can point to two and anything about
it but two can't point back to one
um and we also require that or sorry one
cannot point to one
um so one doesn't self Loop
um and solutions are any index such that
ex it's successor is not itself so it
doesn't point to itself but uh it's
successor
points to itself so it's like
here
this guy here is a solution and this
should be highlighted but I think the
Highlight is a little bit too weak
um
yeah
okay so in tfnb we typically study the
uh turing machine complexity of uh code
search problems however it's been
natural to look at other models of
computation so pfmp like originally was
yeah the study of total MP
3 functional version of NP
um but we can study like
other models of computation instead
um one very natural one is decision
trees
um a missile correspond essentially like
this will come out and give us like
Oracle separations
um so if our complexity model is a
decision tree then a search problem is
in pfnp
um if it's Solutions can be verified by
low def decision
so formally you know for every solution
um there's a polylog uh depth decision
tree
um
such that that decision tree outputs one
on that input if and only if uh that
input and that solution are
um yeah so the the study of these like
decision tree uh tfnp classes uh was
initiated by
um beam Clegg and polyatza
okay sorry he's not here so it's okay
um yeah and so that they showed that uh
if you get separations between these
tfnp classes in the decision Tree World
they apply uh Black Box separations or
generic
so this could help you understand the
landscape of these
and very recently in uh in exciting work
um they showed that actually certain
proof systems are equivalent to uh
decision Treaty of MP class
uh so we're going to say that a proof
system uh is characterized by a tfnd
class if if roughly the uh the problems
class are equivalent to what can be
efficiently proved
okay
so here we have the resolution is equal
to PLS we have a bunch of other
characters
um okay so why why do we have these
equivalences between uh proof systems
and things that are reducible to or
things that are in pfeff
okay
um and the real reason is that these uh
decision tree tfnp which helped denote
by tfnp to the DT
um can really be thought of as the study
of the false clause search Problem
claim here which says that
um every uh search problem which is in
decision tree tfmp is equivalent to an
instance of the false clause search
problem for some unsatisfiable CNF
formula
and that's why we're getting these
characterizations of uh tfmp classes by
proof systems and the proof of this is
pretty simple
um
it just comes out of the fact that to be
in uh decision tree tfmp you have to be
um verified by like low depth decision
treats
okay so yeah uh so if the search problem
is in uh tfmp then there's low depth
decision trees or poly log depth
decision trees
um which verify the solutions for it uh
we can write down a dnf for each of
these little decision trees in just a
standard way you know we take a
disjunction over all the one paths in
the decision tree
um and then we can write down the CNF
formula
the negation of the and or the negation
of these dnfs and what it's saying is
that R is not total
this is this is false because we're
looking at total search problems this is
an unsatisfiable cmf formula and
moreover if you falsify a clause of this
search from uh if you falsify a clause
of one of these dnfs
um then uh
that corresponding uh solution has to be
in the uh
has to be a solution to uh
yeah
and so that's why you're really getting
this characterization these
correspondences between tfmp classes and
improves
foreign
[Music]
this is this is not like original work
here uh but I want to go over the
characterization of resolution by PLS to
give you guys like an example
of how you showed something like this
um and so for this we need
to actually Define what these black box
or these decision tree Productions are
um so we Define tfmp class subclasses
it's everything that is
reducible by low depth decision trees to
a particular search Problem
um yes so
um yeah so search problem one search
problem reduces to another
SNR
um if there's low depth decision trees
first we have a set of decision trees
turning inputs to S into inputs to R
then we solve R we get seen solution and
then we have low depth decision trees
which translate each of the solutions
back to a solution to the initials
problem
uh and so that's that's reduction
um and then the complexity so we're
going to measure the complexity as the
number of variables of the of the
problem that we're reducing to uh like
log the number of variables plus the
maximum depth of these decisions
so D plus y over
um yeah so now I want to show you the
resolution uh is equivalent to PLS and
for this we're not going to use a
standard like size measure we're going
to use this very natural complexity
measure
um
which is for resolution proofs it's
going to be equal to logarithm of the
size plus the the width of the proof
this is sort of non-standard but it's
extremely natural
um
this is kind of what all of these
lifting theorems are actually like the
complexity parameter all these lifting
theorems are using
um
if you wanted to get rid of this
complexity measure and just use size
then it would be equal to low
yeah
so yeah I want to show that uh
sorry that should be PLS so the DP is
equal to search sabath uh such that f as
a polylog so that first app should be
search f
so PLS is exactly the search uh the the
total problems that are equal to the
search problem for CNF formulas that low
so here's the
um complete problem again for POS the
sink of dad problem
um and so in order to prove this
equivalence we want to show that you
know if we have a small resolution proof
then we can get a small reduction from
uh from search F to uh Cinco Dag
what direction the other direction we
want to show that is we have a small
reduction from
a search problem to uh yeah we can get a
resolution proof of the course
okay so here's a I'm just going to do it
by example here's a resolution proof
um we're going to have one uh vertex for
each
pause and the proof I've arranged them a
little pyramid line
on the floor
um
okay and so I have to Define what each
of these decision trees are so first for
all the output trees I'm just going to
make them self Loop
these are like setting them up to be
Solutions
okay
um and
for each of the non-leaf things I'm
going to make them query the variables
of the Clauses which uh they at which
point gave to those these two Clauses
for example uh T2 is here is going to
query uh
what variable X and Y
and it's going to point to the
um point to the node corresponding to
the child which is falsified by this
thing so this is just the standard
reduction uh that you've seen that like
you know resolution proofs imply
protocol like uh decision trees for the
for the false
yes
so for example here
um on the assignment X being 0 1 uh
we're going to get this instance of
uh
uh so again yeah each of the nodes
points to the uh the child which is
falsified by it
um and then yeah
so since resolution is Sound Solutions
are going to end up being
um and now we have to define the output
trees and that's pretty simple you just
you know output the corresponding false
class
um so in the other direction uh slightly
more complicated so now you suppose you
have a reduction from uh search F uh to
Cinco dag and we want to get a small a
low complexity resolution
um so we're going to use for this the
the characterization of resolution
proofs uh by deleted approver games so
the delay approver games you have like
two players
um
proverb and a delayer at each step the
proverb uh chooses a variable and the
layer sets it either zero or one
um and then the prover is allowed to
forget a set of variables
so you should think of the approvers
constructing a partial assignment at
every step it adds an additional
variable to the partial assignment
um and then maybe it forgets some of the
some of the variables that passes
and the game is going to end when the
partial assignment falsifies a clause
um
and so we have this forgetting thing
because we're going to measure the width
this partial assignment and this width
corresponds to like essentially the
width of a resolution
um so I'll say that a w prover strategy
is a strategy for the prover like it
tells what the tells us what the prover
does at every step
um which ends the game while remembering
that most W variables at any time so the
the partial assignment uh
uh from those W bits
okay and uh uh it's kind of a standard
theorem I won't prove it here but it's
not difficult but if you have a w
proofer strategy then uh you get a
resolution proof of uh
you can
okay so now we want to show that if we
have a reduction for the
um from uh this from search F to Cinco
dag we can actually extract out a uh a
resolution for a strategy for the the
proverb
and here's what we're going to do uh
it's pretty simple so we'll start at the
first node
um we'll so the first note is defined by
decision tree which queries the
variables that search have
and we want to find where this first
node points where it's successor
um so what we're going to do is we're
going to query all the variables along
the path in this decision tree and we're
going to remember all of them
so when I say we remember T1 I mean we
remember all the variables that we
created along with half if you want to
figure out where it pointed we'll learn
where it points here it points to three
will then query key free
figure out where it points so we'll
remember all the variables in that path
um and then we're going to forget T3 we
we don't need P3 anymore all we need to
remember is q1
like that
um
T1 yes of course sorry
um yeah and then again we'll query P4
and we'll keep doing this so at each
step we're going to remember basically
I'm about two pointers
uh and this is enough because remember
our Solutions are the form like an arrow
pointing to something that Some Loops
and So eventually because we keep going
because everything and I will only point
to itself or further we're going to
eventually hit one of the solutions and
when we hit a solution like this we can
just query the output decision tree to
learn the false
because this reduction from search F to
uh sync of dag you know uh
solve the search problem uh this thing
is correct and so this gives us a
strategy for the prover
um we remember it most twice or three
times the depth of these decision trees
and thus it gives us a small risk
okay and so that's how you get these
sort of characterizations now there's
there's uh ones for uh PBA for example
which is that two mil Stone sets and all
these other ones which are a bit more
complicated than that
um but you can yeah get lots of
characterizations between psnb classes
and improve systems
um and then so
uh in the other world where we're
looking at communication problems and
this monotone cars from vigorous in game
we can also Define like a tfn keyword
now rather than using our model of
computation being decision trees rather
than using these decision tree
reductions we can use uh efficient
communication reductions
um and in the same world we are going to
get characterizations
um
uh of these PLS classes by monotone
circuit models
um
and yeah that's what's shown this works
by uh Goose kamath Robert and sokoloff I
believe uh
and so yeah PLS is equal to monitor
circuits I think this dates back to
actually like uh rasparov
um and yeah we have a whole bunch of
other things
um and now
um
I mean there's there's some exciting
observations from this first is that
when you have like both uh communication
and a decision tree characterization of
the same pfm class we immediately get an
interpolation
and this just follows from the fact that
uh communication protocols can simulate
decision trees
and so here's like a lot of the
interpolation theorems
um and the other direction
um we get yeah uh you can sort of think
of these query to communication lifting
theorems as relating the communication
version of uh tfnb class to the decision
tree
there's is a lot of them
um
so kind of the upshot of all this is we
can understand when when we're like we
can kind of get a road map of when we
expect to get an interpolation theorem
and a lifting theorem between model of
computation and the proof system uh by
understanding when uh
cfmp classes submit characterizations
um so a natural question is like under
what conditions does a tfmp class admit
a characterization of a proof system and
uh that's a good one
[Music]
um
so uh in this recent work with uh
Russell and Sam we give uh
sort of an answer for this
um
so we give some necessary and sufficient
conditions for this
um
yeah so in the proof complexity World
um we show that every tfmp class has a
proof system which characterizes it so
that is here I've defined pfmp class to
be a class to be to have a complete
problem
um so we don't expect like tfmp itself
to have
okay and the proof systems it's just
very obvious it's kind of dumb proofs
are just reductions to the complete
problem for that tfmp class
um so a little bit more formally uh the
canonical proof system for this class is
you know you fix a
um a C9 formula H such that search H is
equivalent to the uh so the problem to
the complete problem I'm not even sure
if that's actually necessary
um and then a proof is just a reduction
so it's a tuple uh it specifies
um so for a reduced search F to search H
with some unstancy enough F so right
back up and say that so this is a proof
of an unsat CNF Formula F uh and so a
proof of this formula is just a
reduction from search F to search H so
in particular we specify n prime the
number of variables on which H is
defined
um and we just and we specify the like
input and output decision trees
this is a this is a cookware outproof
system uh you can efficiently verify
these
um these proofs you just check that it's
actually a a valid reduction
that's One Direction
um and then the other one is like under
what conditions does a proof system
admit a pfnp characterization
um
so here this may be a little bit more
interesting we showed that
um
this is the case whenever a proof system
has short proofs of its own soundness
uh so this is like an efficiently
verifiable uh encoding of a reflection
principle about itself
uh and a reflection principle is sort of
a statement that says
um if a formula has a p proof then that
formulas uh
the sense of tautology uh or
unsatisfiable depending on
and by efficiently verifiable I want
this to be written down in like polyline
group
and the second condition is just it kind
of just comes from the fact that we're
dealing with decision tree reductions
here we want the proof system to be
closed under decision
so that means basically if the proof
system has a small proof of F and you
stick in a bunch of small decision trees
for the variables in F
blast it down to see in a formula then
it should have a small proof of the
composed and uh for this complexity
measure a lot of standard proof systems
satisfy this like resolution Charlie
Adams can also on stats like everything
we have a characterization for
um so this is not very respective
um okay so uh I can talk about this a
little in a little bit more depth
um so a reflection principle yeah is a
statement of this form uh so you have a
proof system p and some parameters n m
and C uh so n's the number of variables
of the formula
um m is number Clauses the formula and C
is like the complexity parameter of the
proof
um and the reflection principle says
that so now we're dealing we're going to
deal with reputations
um
it says it asserts that both that so it
takes its input Formula F and a claimed
proof Pi uh and an assignment Alpha and
it's going to claim that uh Pi is a is a
p proof of F and so a refutation of f
um but also that the the formula is
satisfiable uh like in particular Alpha
satisfies the formula so it's it's an
unsatisfiable format
um
yeah uh so in finding this we just fix
the standard encoding of the SAT thing
um but in order to write down this proof
statement there's lots of ways to do it
right there's there's tons of different
ways you can encode a
um
uh for for fixed proof system there's
tons of ways you could write down its
proof uh in like an efficiently
verifiable manner by efficiently
verifiable I'm going to need that
that's why it's these parameters
um so each different way of encoding uh
this proof statement could possibly
generate a different key effect class
you know you could you can add in a ton
of extra information in this encoding of
proof that would make it very easy to
solve
it
um but so we showed that for each
particular encoding we get some uh
so yeah so then the proof of the theorem
is that you know if you have a proof
system which is closed under decision
tree Productions
um and has polylog uh complexity proofs
of the reflection principle or a
reflection principle then it's
characterized by the TFM class which is
uh is defined by everything that's
reducible uh to the search problem for
the reflections
so now one thing to point out is yes
there are different
uh possible place of formulating the
proof things that's approved
um and they give you different tfnd
classes but where because of this
uh for such a proof system uh all these
all these tfmd classes will themselves
be equivalent
so it's really just one tfmp class yeah
yeah
yeah so this is pretty easy to to prove
so first uh because so we've required
that the reflection principle was
efficiently verifiable and therefore the
search problem for it is in tfmp so that
was why we needed this edition of
Revival
environment
and then we want to prove the two
statements the first is that if the
search problem if a search problem
reduces to the reflection principle uh
or the search button for the reflection
principle then we get a proof of uh the
formula for which the search problem was
and then the other direction if we have
an efficient proof of a formula then we
can get a reduction
okay so the first Direction's very
simple it just follows from the fact
that we're closed and our proof systems
closed under decision tree reductions uh
so if we have a small
um if we have a small proof for the
reflection principle then because the
proof system is closed and the decision
tree reductions we're going to get a
small proof of
the other Direction's a little bit more
interesting
um
so now if you have an efficient proof of
uh of a formula uh we want to show this
reduction
um so we pick a efficient proof of the
formula half
um and we're going to take our
um
our reflection principle
um and we want to you know we want to
construct a reduction from the search
problem of f to the reflection principle
or the search bomb for the reflection
principle and we can sort of look at the
reflection principle right so the
reflection principle says that
um you know that Pi is a is a proof of F
and if it's satisfiable so if we
actually fix a valid proof of f then the
satisfiable part's going to be the false
Arch and so under a fixing of Pi and F
we essentially get back an instance
um yeah so we fix High f
um and this this leaves us only uh the
truth of Simon Alpha is the free
variables uh which you know uh will then
plug in the assignment to search at
Um this can be done using constant depth
decision trees
um and because Pi is of low complexity
of the number of variables of the
reflection principle after after the
substitution uh is not going to be much
more than the number of areas
so the the reductions yeah again simple
you just take the reflection principle
hardwire the proof and the formula uh
that you want to do the production for
um and now you have to Output
now in order to solve the search problem
uh for this formula you actually have to
Output a false class
um yeah so that's the that's the theorem
again
um and we can show that this canonical
proof system for a tfnp class can
actually prove reflection principles
about itself
it's not too difficult to show uh and
then so the crawler of that is just the
TF banking class
um system admits a characterization by a
tfmp class if and only if uh it's close
interdecision tree reductions and can
prove uh
and uh some last couple of minutes I'll
just go over uh our results for circuit
complexity we get analogous things for
circuit complexity
um with pretty similar proofs
um yeah so question here is when does
the gsmp class
ific characterization
um
so yeah for every tfmb class we get a
circuit a monotone circuit model out of
it
um and in the other direction we show
that
um
a monotone circuit model gives rise to a
characterizing pfmp class if and only if
the model monotone circuit model has a
universal family of functions so a
universal family
um
is a monotone function f such that for
you know if you take a partial function
G and if you have a small computation of
G in that model then there's a string
such that F restricted by that string
gives you the same output as
yeah and the second one is it's a market
Circle I'll actually compute stuff right
G is a monotone
yeah yeah so if uh you know C is a
monitor model if uh C efficiently
computes a function G
which has to then be monotone okay so it
has to be in the class in the class yeah
yeah of course
bounded complexity
um so we have a kind of
yeah I don't want to Define it too much
because it's
like we defined it as these like
monotone partial complexity measures a
list of properties but it kind of models
in space
circuit models
just something roughly something that's
not even foreign
circuit models to be closed under like
right we're using communication
reductions here so communication like
low communication the same thing as low
depth formulas so we want it to be
closer
okay
um and so I'm going to end with uh
perhaps the most interesting open
problem out of this I think
um so we saw that uh from if you have a
tfmp characterization of a proof system
or sorry a tfmp characterization of the
tfib class characterizes the same uh
like Ubuntu circuit and a crew system
then you immediately get an
interpolation theorem out of it but what
about economics can you show that if you
have a circuit model and a fruit system
to characterize the same class can you
prove a lifting theorem in the other
direction
it's like a generic lifting Theory
I'm not sure I understand the question
so
can you show this if if some tfnb class
P has if it's decision tree versions
characterized by a proof system
communication version is characterized
by a um oh I see then do automatically
get them yeah can you can you prove like
a generic one that says given those two
conditions you get a listing here
I think that's a really exciting problem
uh foreign
just like lifting with the indexing
gadgets so if you know just a total that
it gives you like big like how it
conflicts the circuits if you have like
and you know that for example the
resolution has is very interpolation
process
yeah sure
uh so you're asking whether
um
uh but you're you're asking whether
um if you have an interpolation
to give you some kind of lifting color
I don't see why that's the case
right could you could you say some more
so do you hear me now yeah yeah
so uh
so lifting theorems
you start with something weak and you
get like a strong lower bounds in some
Stern model right
uh yeah so I'm saying that if your proof
system has feasible interpolation
property for example
so in particular this means that if you
have a decision MP pair and you have a
short proof then you get a small
circuits that separates like these two
NP pairs
so if you have like this lifting theorem
which says that you are you start with
something weak and you get like a high
complexity function then you can write
this thing as a CNF and use the
interpolation property to get a so I'm
asking whether you can take a if you
have a small circuit in some model can
you translate that then into a small
proof in a proof system
okay okay
that's right there's lots of definitions
of what a what a lifting theorem is so
I'm using this communication to or query
to communication looking here
indexing is
they don't know how to do
some problems
foreign
like
my favorite example is you can Define
tfnp with these uh
triangle trees if you've read the
monotone circuit lifting papers they
Define these triangle bags roughly it's
the thing that it's equivalent to
monotone circuits so if you define pfn
via these triangle trees you're going to
get PLS The Cutting planes and
uh
um
so you can you can change what the
underlying model of computation is and
get a hold of the world tfsd
characterization so it might lead to
classes that are so far resistant to
this thing
yeah yeah yeah yeah so what Tony's
getting at is like we have
characterizations of a bunch of uh tfnp
classes in the city model uh
go way back let me see if I can find it
um
one that's missing here is PVP uh can
you get a pfn I can get a proof system
the care crisis PDP it's a great
question
um and uh
yeah yeah so sorry yes you're right can
you get like a natural one like one that
we like look at in in first complexity
like I don't know I don't know a good
way to Define natural but like my proof
system is not natural we don't want to
think of it
um so like yeah if you get a natural
system for PVP and I think Electronics
if you guys maybe if you change the
underlying model of computation it could
be something
so so by changing the undergoing model
of computation you mean
to to some other kind of decision trees
where you're branching on something
other than variables yeah yeah we're
like yeah like fans boards like cnfs or
something like that I mean
we're just talking about classes of
problems
we have closure under decision trees if
you're looking at any stronger model
decisions
so yeah but you might not be able to get
it for decision
you might not get the decision tree
reduction sorry the reduction
might not there might be one but not a
decision true one oh so you're saying I
think you might not have a complete
problem under decision tree reduction
that's a good question I just
sorry there's a question on this
uh
it was answering okay okay
um so can you go outside with the
reflection principles
so I mean like
sometimes it's it feels like it's not so
obvious to write down
up the one where you actually have your
Independence yeah like sometimes it
feels like it's not so obvious to like
write down what the proof would be at
the scene like like for polynomial
calculus for instance right like
yeah
we do the characterizations
sorry maybe an example fabulous but for
like a static for instance that's maybe
less obvious right like yeah um so like
for PC it's a step it's a derivational
system line by line but if I have like
SOS right it's like not so obvious so if
you like have any idea well no I don't
understand the problem
so as long as you have like a format for
proofs you can write down a reflection
principle
you just need to write down the
verification procedure for all right I
guess the problem is that the
verification procedure itself needs to
be like
uh easily refutable in order for it to
be interesting right
because I mean for SOS you're gonna I
guess my point is that you're gonna have
to do some sort of subbing right in
order to like verify that the proof
right equal to one and so it's not
obvious that that could be efficiently
verified by like resolution or something
you know what I mean not that it is well
for a general approach system
yeah so so I guess so here you wouldn't
have to verify it in resolution we would
just have to verify it in sum of squares
um I guess that's true yeah right so
um
and you're allowed to introduce any kind
of supplementary variables that you need
so
um
you wouldn't need to uh yeah it may even
be verifiable in resolution if you
phrase it correctly
yes
do I have horse lives
well I mean that's the like maybe that's
the second job incredible open it to the
audience yeah so TBD stands for Tony's
birthday
[Laughter]
okay
and uh I guess we've had many questions
but let's take the organizers of this
wonderful Workshop
yeah thank you everyone it came for this
workshop and participated and
contributed talks and
um uh and of course the Simon's events
and Rahul and Tony and myself
thank you and uh well see you see you
next time
[Applause]
okay